let me show you the Japanese way to make
chicken wings so what makes these
different is the use of sake you
basically let it sit in sake after
salting and this does several things
including removing bad odors tenderizing
the meat adding Umami and a slight
sweetness along with allowing for better
caramelization on the skin I've tested
this several times and letting it sit
for eight hours makes such a difference
in flavor but if you only have 30
minutes that'll work too then after the
wings are dried and salted place in a
broiler for about 10 minutes on each
side until the skin is browned and
sprinkled with Japanese red pepper on
top